this video is sponsored by Squarespace
secrets
[Music]
what on earth happened how did a
character with this sort of presence
turn into this towards the end of Dragon
Ball and the beginning of Z piccolo was
an extremely interesting character
charismatic and tough with a host of
conflicting motivations and for many
piccolo was their favorite character
despite his less than stellar
performances as of late and I want to
know what you guys think his Piccolo's
current position good neutral or bad
click here with that said a compa
counter-argument I've heard is that
piccolo is now after letting go of his
evil ways he's after adopting a new way
of life and while it might not be as
interesting he's found what makes him
happy and that should be enough for us
well to that I say I hate this argument
it seems excessively reductionist to
label it as simply a path piccolo was
inevitably marching down especially when
you consider similar characters like
Vegeta that are happy and also made the
transition successfully so why can't
piccolo today I'm taking an honest
in-depth look at the writing behind
would have Dragon Balls most popular and
respected characters would that has
experienced a massive fall from grace
and in some cases has been QB Li guyi
duties hidden until okay he's the
reincarnation of the demon cake
[Music]
this is pickled
[Music]
there isn't one simple aspect in the
writing of piccolo I could point to
that's the reason for the downward
spiral his character has experienced in
recent decades it's actually a lot more
complicated than that and in fact it's a
combination of several easily overlooked
the tributes that make up his story and
his circumstances I'm going to paint a
picture for you here and draw a
conclusion at the end and to draw the
conclusion we gotta start where all
stories do the beginning the
twenty-third Tenkaichi Budokai is a
section of Dragon Balls story I think is
grossly underappreciated and sort of
acts as a hybrid of everything that made
Dragon Ball wonderful with strong flares
of what Dragon Ball Z would ultimately
become and man did piccolo establish
himself in this section having decimated
the Z warriors sealed away cubby and
mortally wounded Goku during the battle
which by the way was the first utilize a
beam struggle and a giant bag I throw
down against Goku I mean let's call a
spade a spade the Vegeta Goku fight
totally copied these two aspects from
Piccolo's fight but I digress
Piccolo's goal of eliminating Goku from
this world in order to conquer it was
all but assured however as often is the
case Goku was underestimated
on this particular point in the story
piccolo is still facilitating the role
of antagonist and as is the case with
many Dragon Ball antagonists that is the
title that one does not hold on to for
long and if they can't find the new role
to occupy they will be lost in the same
space tension HOD poor Yamcha and
chiaotzu have found themselves once
Buuren however the position piccolo
currently finds himself in at this
moment in time isn't bad at all it's
actually a great one and I say that
because at this moment the time he is
the uncontested strongest fighter after
Goku and he still has his own individual
goals with which to strive towards
however over the five-year time skip
between the end of Dragon Ball on the
start of Z picollo doesn't do anything
and this I think was the moment that
started piccolo down this losing path
and this becomes immediately obvious
with the introduction of a certain
character
[Music]
[Applause]
Regina immediately swoops it as someone
stronger and someone that could
potentially be in line with the good
guys additionally during this section of
the story Piccolo's character arc met a
speedy albeit satisfying conclusion
however with his arc having come full
circle it was known not immediately
obvious what he would do next and I
think that's part of the problem which
results in fewer and fewer major
involvements as the story marched
forward feeding into the back road
helping a decent amount with Frieza even
less with cell and even less again with
majin buu now he did receive training on
King Kai's planet and a special fusion
with nail and subsequently copy but in
reality this amounted to nothing more
than window dressing in other words they
were just mechanisms to stall within the
story and I'm still no myth that commie
and Piccolo's fusion dipped about to
anything other than that there was the
potential of some real emotional
storytelling over the long term in my
view looking back they entirely wasted
it but let's back up for a second
in the Saiyan saga piccolo establishes
two aspects of his character that would
stay with him forever his strategic
sensibilities and his strong
relationship with go home and boy do I
plan talking about that hot second
however unlike Vegeta in many respects
piccolo really struggled to and in other
cases outright failed to remain
competitive with the main cast and I
know what you're thinking no I do not
think Vegeta say in biology matters at
all that is a story mechanic that was
written by Akira Toriyama one that could
easily have been omitted by him if he so
chose heck even if we ignore that he's
already given insane and absurd power
boost to a ton of other characters with
that said however because piccolo
strength didn't follow Goku's closely
enough it resulted in his minor role in
Dragon Ball super and in the most recent
film as a glorified homing beacon for
the important characters Goku and Vegeta
still though Piccolo's lack of strength
is sort of a symptom isn't it a symptom
of a much bigger problem so wats
Piccolo's problem well in a nutshell it
all boils down to the roles that are
available within a series in TV a rule
is industry speak for a character or
part to play within that series the role
of main character in Dragon Ball is
filled by Goku and will remain such
until further notice
so it's not available but would roll
that has had numerous people play it
that
has tremendous value in screen time is
Goku Seidman the Seidman character in
Dragon Ball is essentially Goku's
right-hand man someone that performs
very well but can't quite get the job
done at the very end effectively
creating the perfect scenario and stakes
for gohu to step up to the plate and
save the day that is the purpose of this
role and this has been Vegeta's purpose
for the majority of his run in Dragon
Ball continuing to this very day woods
vegeta began facilitating this Siteman
role for goku we saw less and less of
piccolo and even Crillon and if you
think about it characters like Crillon
woods occupied Goku's right-hand man
spot and while they were behind Goku
they competed extremely well in the
story during that time period many of
you might not recall this interaction
from the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai but
prior to piccolo facing off against Goku
in the finals he fought Crillon and
krillen managed to surprise everyone in
how well he performed however in the end
he would come up short in his effort
needing to leave it to the stronger Goku
remind you of anyone know a new car
no gumbo death yeah this is the role of
the side man and as you move farther and
farther down the totem pole you get less
impressive moments and less screen time
overall in the universe six tournament
arc piccolo enter to fight universe six
is frost and in competing he did better
than we thought he would however much
like the quillin's tension hoods and
young chess of the past he had to step
aside for his superior Vegeta in other
words since the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai
piccolo has gone down from antagonist to
side man - Yamcha
at this current moment in time piccolo
is on par with Yamcha performance from
the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai he has
completely different sensibilities and
personality but his standing within the
series hierarchy is that but I hear you
asking why did Vegeta claim that roll
over piccolo
well piccolo and Vegeta are both former
bad guys turned good meaning they
underwent a positive change arc and
these changes while they're happening
are fascinating to watch as viewers but
if you were to compare the length of
time piccolo took to reach his
conclusion - Vegeta's you'll notice that
Vegeta story was much much longer and
filled with much more hardship
not to mention all of this
story for vegeta took place woods
piccolo had completed his own wood
because of this while piccolo was static
doing his best to help out with the gang
Vegeta was undergoing major changes to
his personality causing trouble for the
main characters and overcoming his own
internal demons translation he was more
interesting at the time additionally
from a character perspective compared to
piccolo Vegeta is much more likely to
mouth off and get into trouble meaning
he's a much more active character
naturally and if given the choice
between a stoic silent antihero and a
brash cocky one Akira Toriyama would be
crazy not to choose the most active
character to fill the series character
roles this might be the biggest
advantage Vegeta's character type had
going for and that is the added benefit
of being the same species as the main
character Goku leading whatever shiny
new form Goku achieved Vegeta would
technically be capable of mimicking in
theory and given how insanely successful
Super Saiyan transformations were in the
series it meant Vegeta would like Goku
be able to sell many more toys as a
result and that more than anything else
is the name of the game here however I
hear you clamoring you said Piccolo's
character art came to an end which took
him out of the spotlight because it was
less interesting as a result compared to
the next in line Vegeta
so when VG is character arc and did why
did it happen for him to well that's a
great question and you're absolutely
right his character arc reached his
climax for the most part right in the
middle of the Majin Buu saga he said his
goodbyes to his loved ones and in a
blinding flash of light gave up his life
for his family and friends and what
happened when he made his return to the
action against Kid Buu it became
painfully obvious that he was not
remotely on Goku's level anymore and
this is about where his character would
normally have been recycled into the
piccolo position but he got lucky the
series abruptly ended and was rebranded
18 years later and that's not all they
retconned his character slightly in
Dragon Ball super in the case of piccolo
his character took a large hit in terms
of the material he was given
particularly Jurga the majin buu arc and
part of that problem was going Gohan's
character role shifted dramatically with
this saga and because Piccolo's
character had become intrinsically
- Gohan what his character wasn't given
a tshane piccolo suffered similar
consequences additionally since Vegeta's
unveiling there simply haven't been any
new characters introduced that threaten
his position the closest really is majin
buu and he's not gonna be doing it
anytime soon as well as that given how
established he is in the role now it's
difficult to see anyone else occupy it
he is so engrained into this part of the
series the idea that there ever will be
anyone as Goku's number two other than
Vegeta will feel strange which I would
imagine was the impetus behind this
Dragon Ball super spoof by TFS check it
out why did you decide to pay hit to
kill you it is I don't know he just does
things you know things you can't I can't
go through life only knowing the same
thing day in day out 15 years I just
don't excite you anymore is that it No
piccolo wasn't like this when you came
along oh that's what this is now
diversity and the cast of characters is
important the few glimpses we got to see
piccolo shine and super were a breath of
fresh air to me he offers so much more
aesthetically to the series than many
might think when 100% of your main cast
are sins then things become very saving
I don't want to get bored of seeing
Vegeta and Goku and and a great way of
making their involvement feel more
distinctive special is by including
characters like piccolo that look
nothing like Saiyans that have vastly
different fighting styles I mean look at
this fight choreography
[Music]
it's a real shame that much of this can
be boiled down to piccolo simply being
in the wrong place at the wrong time
having been born into a promising
character role with tons of depth and
potential for long-term main cast
involvement as the likes of Goku Vegeta
and Gohan continued to transform it to
bigger and better versions of themselves
piccolo transformed into a plot device a
babysitter and a joke
reflecting on Piccolo's character for
this video was bittersweet it was
wonderful to revisit what is easily in
my opinion the most underrated fight in
Dragonball history but as the story
marched on it started to become more and
more obvious that piccolo wasn't keeping
up finding himself an unfortunate
situation after unfortunate situation
until all that he contributed to
consistently were some funny visuals
sometimes culminating in a character
that is a shadow of what he once was a
series that is less visually interesting
and a character that has regrettably
been humiliated thanks for watching
shoutout to Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video Squarespace is a powerful
online platform that provides you with
the tools to create clean impressive and
professional websites with ease if you
need a website build it with Squarespace
their platform allows you to embed
videos which really helps your website
pop you can link your social media
accounts allowing you to post
simultaneously to all of them you can
even purchase your own domain directly
through Squarespace they really are the
wood stop shop when it comes to starting
your own website and the best part you
can start your free trial today at
squarespace.com and if you use the offer
code totally not mark you can get 10%
off your first purchase
happy website buildings and I'll see you
all in the next video
[Music]
[Music]